I cut out most sugar and bread a year
ago it's now just about a year so but we
we got covered everybody's sick it was
like over Halloween last year we got the
Joe Rogan treatment you know the all the
fancy drugs monoclonal antibodies all
that stuff the kitchen sink they called
it and then after that
I remember I was like I'm hanging out
downstairs and I was eating salami and
cheese and then I was like you know I
realized I didn't eat any sugar today
I'm just not gonna like why start now
and so for the next few months I need
any sugar and I dropped 20 pounds like
like that and then since then I've
rarely eaten sugars or breads but this
past week we went out to eat I had a
bunch of bread my whole week was ruined
like the the last weekend not this past
weekend my whole week was ruined I was
skating I was falling I got bruised all
over I was like why am I falling like
what's I'm not eating that garbage
anymore dude I had some Taco Bell we had
a big Taco Bell Fiesta someone just
bought a bunch of Taco Bell I brought it
here who was that animal yeah 300 a Taco
Bell for the whole office so I ate them
like why I was like corn tortillas only
because I don't want to do the wheat
flour it's all a wise decision that's
right it's a couple corns I thought okay
I ate a couple without the shell I took
away the flour just scooped out the
gooey innards and uh um I ate a couple
like a day later the the flour tortilla
and and my throat was so sore when I
walked I love that you thought that
there was a healthy way to approach Taco
Bell 300 to tuck them I actually I
didn't feel bad yeah the chicken yeah I
think they've improved some of their
ingredients for the last 20 years I I
don't you don't think so I think I think
they downgraded ingredients
significantly just like everywhere else
you look at the food quality it's going
down you look at the nutritional value
it's going down you look at the value of
of just how much you would get from an
average tomato or apple a few years ago
compared to what we have now the GMO
Frankenstein glycophate filled plastic
nonsense bull crap that some people are
saying is food it's not food it's it's
chemically engineered chemicals that
make your brain feel good but utterly
destroy your body and cause inflammation
in a way where your body doesn't know
what to deal with it as as we are seeing
rises in obesity rises in cancer rises
in sicknesses and illnesses that are
going up and up and up why is that
happening well our food is being
deliberately destroyed and centralized
by powerful forces like Bill Gates
Monsanto and other evil people that also
believe that there's too many people in
this world faux food or food
yeah
I'm not looking forward to Bill Gates
food Cube and the poop water you're not
you don't want the poop water yeah you
ever see that photo where it's like
there's a disaster like a hurricane was
coming and then all of the shelves are
stripped bare except for the vegan
section
nobody nobody was like I mean or the
animals when they're presented with real
food and vegan food they're like we're
gonna want that vegan crap we don't want
that GMO genetically modified
Frankenstein made up food in a
laboratory come on and and a lot of the
studies talking about the nutritional
value of them all manipulated all fixed
a lot of the scientists were paid off
just to make it look bad because there's
a big business investment into this you
gotta eat the bugs which is also
horrible for you and gives people
parasites and lectins and all their
horrible things that people have to deal
with that is not good for you you know
what you know what's good for you actual
food you know what we don't have actual
food it's crazy is the Monsanto stuff
really has me concerned because they
weren't in the 90s I don't remember
Monsanto being that big of a deal it's
like 2005 or this one I start to realize
that this Mega Corporation has been
spraying huge swaths of land with this
chemical glyphosate that you brought up
as they have a revolving door within the
FDA and the regulatory government boards
that of course watches over them and
decides major decisions for them they
started working with other biotech
Industries I don't know who exactly is
doing it all but they genetically modify
seeds to be resistant to a pesticide or
I think it's an herbicide that they
create called glyphosate so they G they
genetically modify seeds that can resist
this herbicide and then so the farmers
have to buy the the Monsanto seed in
order to resist the Monsanto herbicide
otherwise
otherwise they're on their own in a lot
of ways and so for profit they'll do
that but then once you start spraying
your land with glyphosate there's no
turning back you can't use normal seeds
because they'll die off from the
glyphosate you have to keep buying these
genetically modified seeds and it
destroys not only the bad bacteria but
the good bacteria as well so essentially
when you're taking something that's like
glycipate a lot of scientists have
described it as taking antibiotics
because it destroys also your gut biome
and with the destruction of your gut
biome you get a lot of horrible symptoms
that are are shown and highlighted and
are increasing in our society you not
only get irritable bowel syndrome but
you also get mental problems you also
get physical health problems you also
get the destruction of your immune
system a lot of this is correlated with
just your gut the engine of your human
body that's being utterly eviscerated
not just by medical doctors giving out
uh you know antibiotics like like
they're candy but also because of the
food which contains glycopy it's gotten
to the point where when they go to
harvest wheat if it's if they want to
speed up the Harvest they needed to get
ready to harvest faster so they need to
dry it out because it's still wet so
they'll use glyphosate as a desiccant to
dry out the wheat right before they
harvest it so I mean if you don't have
organic wheat I swear that I notice a
difference in The Taste between organic
wheat and non or any any other NBC News
has an article that I think might be
worth pulling up it's titled a potential
cancer-causing chemical is sprayed on
much of America's Farmland here is where
it used it is used the most and of
course we're talking about the weed
killer glycephate by Monsanto that now
is controlled by Bayer the company that
also a couple years ago knowingly gave
out you know just this just medication
linked with AIDS is Roundup glyphosate
yes yes it is yes popular weed killers
allegedly to cancer stores widespread
concern yeah and there's many lawsuits
that have been successfully launched
against Santo because they are showing
the emails the data the fudged uh you
know scientific data The fudged
Regulators that were bought off by them
that of course knowingly knew that they
hey there's a link here to cancel we're
just going to use it anyway we're going
to suppress this story look at this
clumps of dandelions have popped up in
your yard so you reach for a bottle of
Roundup the popular weed killer it's
known for being effective but its main
ingredient glyphosate is getting a lot
of attention because of lawsuits alleges
alleging links to cancer I just want to
say this
dandelions weeds you eat them you make
dandelion tea and you eat them it's uh
so they were brought here I think you
told me this they were brought here from
Europe or someone did and uh for their
medicinal purposes and we see them all
over the place but they're actually not
not native to North America they were
like prized back in the day and I guess
in Appalachia it's a common thing to
take the heads and batter and deep fry
them and they apparently taste like
mushrooms it's like really good so uh
they're not weeds if if here's what you
do if any you harvest them and if you're
concerned about what anyone might say
when you try to offer them deep fried
dandelions just call them dandelions
they won't know what you're talking
about and then they'll eat it and you
can tell them it's a dandelion from your
garden or stop being a lazy bum and
actually start working in the fields and
get your hands dirty in the dirt with
good bacteria and actually rip out the
weeds and actually do some real farming
instead of being dependent on a
multinational corporation that of course
is connected to Bill Gates one of their
biggest investors that has been spraying
known uh according to many lawsuits and
court cases a cancer-causing chemicals
on on a lot of the products and a lot of
the environment all around us and it's
also important to note here corn and soy
are some of the biggest products that
are affected by glycipate are the
products that are most sprayed with it
and when you look at corn and soy I
think it's fair to say that this
subsidized crop in the United States has
been leading to a lot of Havoc not only
with monocraft been getting rid of the
nutrients from the soil but but
specifically on a nutritional level
because it's gml because it has so much
glycopate in it we are seeing it
everywhere in our food all the sugars
are synthetic all the sugars have high
fructose corn syrup your mayonnaise has
high fructose no mine doesn't
well the ones
you're taken down we were right taken
down the red sheets and the packets of
Heinz mayonnaise had corn syrup in it
yeah yeah but uh the helmet stuff I have
has no cornstarch watch out for
glyphosate I'll say it like I want it no
it's glyphosate it doesn't have any
respect for me and and you know I don't
care they've remarketed uh high fructose
corn syrup as fructose glucose fructose
yeah so if you see that on your lane
that's high fructose corns you know my
childhood wasn't it 80s 90s my favorite
my favorite 92 is when it got popular my
friend my favorite rebranding is table
syrup oh I know so corn syrup yeah it's
just it's corn syrup marketed it as like
a breakfast pancake syrup or whatever
yeah yeah just think about how
disgusting this is okay look there's a
reason why we would put maple syrup on
our food it's like maple syrup is real
food so you know you get out of a tree
it's sugar it's it's a it's a you know
product you can do things with it you
can make they make like little little
Maple discs you put in your car coffee
they're fantastic and so then people
like to put maple syrup on their
breakfast so then somebody was like Hey
look this corn syrup is cheaper to
produce so they started making you know
corn syrup additives and calling it
maple syrup eventually the government's
like hey you can't call it that
basically you have this disgusting
chemical mix on your table to pour onto
your already starch breakfast I just
find it absolutely disgusting that's
wild table syrup I love how they
rebranded it yeah tables I used to do it
of maple syrup I'd be like all right
let's do this I need a sugar Spike and I
do I do like a shot of maple syrup and
it would be like like God entered my
body and gave me wisdom and joy and all
this and I'm like wow immediately I
wanted another one my body's like yes do
that again so I I would experiment and I
would reach for and I'd do a second shot
and it would taste like I was drinking
black nasty death like it was just like
poison it was just too much sugar like
you don't need the body immediately when
it feels good it wants it again it
doesn't mean that you're going to feel
the same way the second time you do it
so I realize when you want that
addictive second shot just put it down
well high fructose corn syrup has been
engineered in a way so your body doesn't
reject it like it does natural sugar so
if you're eating natural sugar your body
says hey you're getting too much sugar
stop eating all these berries stop
eating all these fruits but but high
fructose corn syrup has been engineered
in a way where that shut off valve can't
exist in your human body and it doesn't
work with it so you're able to consume
huge sums of high fructose corn syrup
and corporations even have a level where
it's the exact amount where your body is
able to take as much of it as as it can
without actually puking and a lot of
Corporations fill it to the Max and try
to go to that extreme level you know the
association point satiation point
exactly for breakfast I've been having
two eggs fresh from chicken City and
three bacon we've been doing just
regular old store-bought bacon but
sometimes if we make it out to the farm
we'll get Farm bacon and you don't need
to add anything to it now Bacon's
already very salty or whatever but you
don't need sugar it's just fat and
protein and it's just it's it's perfect
I like putting a little black pepper on
it's about it
people people who have these crazy
sugary massive breakfast with pancakes
and orange juice and whatever I can't
understand that's so brutal it's kind of
weird how like we've been brainwashed to
think that you need foods with foods
like certain foods like you can't have a
hummus without a scooping cracker like
I'd just ignore the crackers you don't
eat crackers just eat the hummus was it
orange uh juice Edward Bernice and so is
bacon yep they were both the uh at least
okay this is what I read you know this
is what I was told bacon was not a
breakfast food but they were like let's
Market it as like the All-American
breakfast food and orange juice was
because there was an orange Surplus so
the farmers and Distributors were like
how do we sell off without losing money
and he was like
take a portion of the oranges out of the
market juice them and then we'll tell
everybody if one glass of orange juice
has five oranges it's five times as
healthy how about that in reality that
sugar is there's more sugar and orange
juice than like a can of Coke or
something like that so it's and it's
pure fructose just to go to your liver
and it's very very heavy you eat an
orange you're in good shape you know
it's got some sugar but you get a lot of
that dietary fiber and vitamins orange
juices hyper concentrated with no fiber
also when you eat the orange uh eat off
a little bit of that white pith from
inside the it's really good with the
juicy orange part
I had a chocolate covered orange peel
yeah basically we had a bunch everybody
ate it they ate it super fast that was
crazy candied orange peels yeah we we I
bought some thinking like this is going
to be gross and no one's going to want
to eat it it was the first thing to go
people love eating orange peel a lot of
fruits like that can't you eat the
banana peel too do you think so I think
so you wouldn't want to how what do you
just prepare a banana peel I don't know
you can you can uh well I need to
caramelize them and stuff really yeah oh
I think I've seen it it's all plant
matter I mean you know yeah obviously I
think our generation's so conscious of
all this stuff because I was having this
conversation last night about 80s and
90s kids growing up and you think about
the food that we had growing up every
breakfast was a dessert you know we had
Fruity Pebbles and cartoon characters
cookie crisps and stuff and then every
meal was based around pizza for the most
part you had Totino's party pizzas and
Bagel Bites that was my idea growing up
you know and uh and hamburgers so like
we're we're sort of starting to feel the
repercussions of this so I think that
now we're we're kind of a lot more
conscious of it nowadays we were going
by the food pyramid which was yeah so
right it's actually an economic model
like it was made for the same thing
where they want they had so much wheat
production they want to they want to
increase action in the U.S so that we
would just make okay make everyone eat
it all the time every day also before we
go into Super chats I'm getting
information that Viva Frey did not
comply with oh really take down orders
and that his account was just reinstated
without him having to click that he was
wrong oh on Twitter so that's just what
people are sending me and Viva Frey is
saying it on Twitter just for a
direction from the earlier correction
apologies Viva
um glad to hear that you stood your
ground and ultimately it worked out
apparently you could make bacon out of
banana peels what dude I'm telling you
holy oh really yeah that's interesting
you ever make a watermelon steak no this
is actually really cool you take a big
slice of watermelon you put it between
paper towels put in the fridge and leave
it overnight which dries it out a bit
then you can marinate it season it and
bake it and it ends up having the
consistency of like a piece of tuna and
so we would we would we would cook it
with like garlic and onion and maybe
like a little soy sauce for flavor and
then we would make sandwiches with it
and it's delicious because it's it's
it's not there's not a lot of flavor in
it after you you dry it out so you're
basically just getting like a firm
dietary fiber Mash with whatever flavor
you put in it thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there